Hi, class. Dr. Jim here. In this lecture, we're going to be looking at immunity. And
so I really broke this up into the two types of immunity that we have, the innate immunity
and the adaptive immunity. And adaptive is a much more complex system. An innate immunity
is just the basic you have, your barriers on the outside, so your skin, your mucus membranes,
the chemicals, the tears, the saliva, all those things that help prevent organisms from
getting inside of you. And then you have that second line, which is really sitting right
underneath the first line of defense. And so you have these white blood cells that are
there. You have the process of inflammation, which basically causes you to get the white
blood cells to the spot that they need to. And then finally, you have chemical mediators
like the interferon, which is chemicals that turn on the immune system, as well as complement,
which is kind of this cascade of proteins that go through and help fight this thing.
So this one's a really short video. We're just going to talk about the first two lines
of defense. And then we're going to spend a lot of more time on the adaptive immunity
and spending really just kind of combine the two and do that. And again, I separated this
out so it wouldn't be so long and that stuff. So let's take a look at innate immunity. This
is something you're born with. This is not something that you have to develop over time,
like the adaptive. And so that's one of the nice things. And again, most animals have
at least innate immunity. What you're talking about in sex or organisms even lower on the
inverter risk scale all the way up to us. And so innate is something we're born with. And
then the adaptivism or complex type of system that we deal with, especially in humans and
other mammals that we see. So let's take a look at the innate immunity today. And then
the next video is going to look at the adaptive as we go along. Okay. So again, first we'll
talk about innate immunity. I've kind of explained that already a little bit what innate immunity
is. It's something you're born with. And it's your chemical, line of defense, your first
line of defense, those barriers. And then the second line, which is all the cells of
the white blood cells that you have. And then how does innate immunity work in the body?
So explain that again, barriers to keep things out. And then essentially the second line is
to fix anything that happened in the first line. And then we'll look at some of the components
of the first line of defense. Like I said, those are your physical barriers. Again, your
skin, your mucous membranes, the enzymes you produce, some of the other things, sweat glands,
all those other things, which are there, not only for certain functions, but they're also
there for defense as well. And then finally, the second line of defense, which is going
to be mostly your white blood cells. And what I'm talking about are the granulocytes
that we learned in chapter 34 with the blood, and then the agranulocytes, the monocytes.
And so we'll look at those. The B&T lymphocytes, we're going to look at that in the next section.
That's going to be the adaptive. And so again, they're important for adaptive rule. The other
thing about these two is specificity. So with the adaptive immunity or required immunity,
that is something you develop over time, and you have very specific cells that target their
specific functions too. Whereas with these, it doesn't matter if it's a bacteria, virus,
fungus, whatever, in that it's going to respond to it as a foreign agent and destroy, destroy,
destroy. That's kind of their role in the body. They're like basically security guards
watching to make sure nothing gets in and responding when something does. And so that's
what we're going to look at here. So again, pathogens are agents that cause disease, infected
wide range of animals, including humans. And again, really, we talk about pathogens as
any microorganism or organism that causes disease within the humans or other organisms
that way. So causing disease or disrupt tissue dysfunction, or whatever you want to call
that, and trigger some of the responses that we see. Now again, our immune system enables
an animal to avoid or limit many infections. And again, all animals have innate immunity,
which is in defense that's active immediately upon infection, as well as birth. And so it's
one of those things you're born with and you have these sets of features to keep you safe.
The adaptive immunity is something that's only found in vertebrates. And again, it's
a more specialized thing, specialized cells that have specificity as well as memory to
it. And that's going to be another thing that we'll talk about next time is memory
in these cases. Okay. And so again, the innate immunity includes barrier defenses. And again,
it's can be small receptor proteins that bind to structures, count into viruses, bacteria
and microbes. And again, binding the innate immune receptor activates internal defense
responses to a broad range of defense or broad range of pathogens. So if we look at
it on the big scale, so innate or natural immunity is not specific. And so this includes things
like your first line of defense, which is the barriers against skin, mucus membranes,
the secretions from those mucus membranes, the chemicals like the tears in your eyes
have lysosine, which is all things that's why if you get something in your eye, you start
to water your eyes to flush it out as well as provide lysosine to kill those things.
Your ear wax in your ear, the mucus, like I said, sweat on your skin, the saltiness,
again, to keep pathogens at bay. Also your normal floor. And we don't talk a lot about
that as being a defense mechanism, but it does. We know that microbes have it. It can
antagonize other microbes. And so when you have a good collection of good microbes there,
the bad ones can't grow. And so if they're filling out all the spaces, the bad ones can't
be there. So if you keep a good normal flora, you're in good shape. And so that's really
brought along the last 10, 15 years, the whole idea of probiotics, because again, if you get
good microflora in your gut and other parts of your body where they're supposed to be,
then you keep the pathogens at bay. And so that's all part of the first line of defense.
The second line, like I mentioned before, is your innate immune cells, which are mostly
all white blood cells, but not all of the white blood cells. And so again, we'll talk
again about that again. Inflammation complement. And then the antimicrobial substances that
these cells produce. Okay. And then the acquired and adapted, this is going to be the other
video that I'll show you again, the specialized lymphocytes, the B cells, which produce antibodies.
So I'll talk all about that. And then the two types of T cells, the helper T cells, which
help activate the system. And then the killer T cells, which basically do the cell killing.
And so again, we'll talk about this next chapter, our next lecture, I should say, in
that, but for right now, we're just going to focus in on the first and second line of
innate immunity. Now adaptive required develops over exposure. And that involves a very specific
response pathogens. And so we'll talk about that again in the next section. This is what
we're going to look at right now in the innate immunity, which you're born with. And again,
I just bring this up now just to show you that there are the two parts of the system.
Now innate immunity is found in all animals and plants. In invertebrates innate immunity
is the immediate response to infections and serves as the foundation of adaptive immunity.
And so again, you have physical barriers and chemical barriers that protect. That's your
first line of defense. And so again, the anatomical barriers, physical and chemical barriers,
you have the cells, which include phagocyte cells, which eat things. You have the dendritic
cells, which activate and present. And then you have the NK cells and the interleukins
and all that good stuff that are there to trigger the immune response. And then you
also have soluble proteins like compliments, cytokines, chemokines and antimicrobial substances
that all play a role. And this is all released once these cells get activated. And so it's
kind of like this double mechanism. Don't get the cells to activate. They start eating
things and they start producing chemicals, which will then respond in the site of the
infection. But again, this only happens when these things get in through the first line
of defense. And so you have to have a breach in the first line of defense in order for
the second line of offense to start working in this situation. Now again, in invertebrates,
they only have innate immunity. And so again, typically they rely on their exoskeleton
as a physical barrier against infection. Again, their digestive system, the enzyme lysoszyme
breaks down bacterial cell walls, protects them from other pathogens. And then the immune
cells of insects recognize pathogens by binding to molecules of specific viruses and microorganisms.
And each recognition protein of the insect recognizes the broad class of pathogens. And
so you have these other cells that respond in block and they kill, kill, kill, kill. And
so you get phagocytosis, you get release of factors that trigger other cells. And again,
you see enzymes and lysos and other things that go on to protect. And so again, it's
a very simple system, but lots of insects out there. And so we don't really spend a lot
of time. They don't have the adaptive immunity that they do, or that we do. But the innate
immunity does just enough for their immune system to work and prevent from having major
infections and that stuff. And probably some of the reason why insects only have the innate
immunity is just the sheer numbers is that there's just so many of them that it's even
if you lose a few here and there due to infection, it's not a big deal. So you're not going to
develop these great immune systems unless you are fewer a number. And so, and that's
one of the things that you see in the higher level organisms. You don't have as many offspring,
so you're going to have to have better immune systems to respond to these different types
of infections. So I think it's a numbers thing more than anything.
Okay. Again, the hemostites circulate with the hemolymph. And again, remember, in insects,
that's the one thing they don't have the blood in that stuff. So these all circulate around
in that fluid that again is carrying the nutrients in that around the body. They break down and
just break down substances, including bacteria. Then the hemostites are also released anti-microbial
peptides throughout the plasma membranes and fungi and bacteria. And again, that's the
basics of what we see in our innate immunity. And that we have cells that eat things. Okay.
Those are the white blood cells that are phagocytic that eat those are the neutrophils and monocytes.
And then we have the ones that release granules that kill and stimulate the immune system as
well as those that stimulate complement and other things which help destroy these cells.
And so again, just kind of giving an idea of what phagocytosis is. Again, that's the eating
of these cells by the phagocytic cell. They eat the bacteria released, the lysosome that's
the enzymes, and then spit it all out. Now in neutrophils, they tend to just eat and pass
it out or spit it out. Whereas monocytes will actually take some of these components and
put them in a receptor and present them to the third line of defense which we'll look
at next time. So again, just kind of think about that in the back of your mind that we're
going to see the connection of the second and third in the next lecture. Okay. Now again,
innate immunity of vertebrates. Again, the immune system mammals is the best understood
of all vertebrates. And again, these include beard defenses, phagocytosis and antimicrobial
peptides. Again, natural killer cells, interferons and inflammatory response are also only seen
in vertebrates and not in vertebrates. So we have these cells that go in and kill things.
We have interferons which stimulate the immune system. It's probably because we have the adaptive
that they're important. And again, they trigger different types of responses. And then we
have the inflammatory response, which is really the body saying we have an infection. Let's
do something about it. And again, it helps stimulate the rest of the immune system that
we have. Now, barrier defenses. So this is the first line of defense include things like
the skin and mucous membranes of the respiratory urinary and reproductive tracts, really anything
that's open to the outside world. They're around mucous membranes. And again, what they're
there for is to secrete mucus to trap these things to keep them from getting into where
they're supposed to be. And so anywhere you have a opening to the outside world, you're
going to have a mucous membrane along there to catch the microbes that are there. And again,
mucous traps and allows to remove all microbes, many body fluids, including saliva, mucus
and tears are hostile and many microbes because they contain enzymes like lysoszyme, which
break down the bacteria and viruses. And then again, our skin has a low pH and the low pH
of our digestive system. And so that's another thing that we do. So a lot of things that
end up in our lungs, and we'll talk about that. And we talked about this in the respiratory
system with the saliated elevator. What we do is we move this up and then we swallow
it in the middle of the night. And so that's why you wake up a lot of times with the little
bit of roughness in your throat or the frog in your throat, because again, that's a lot
of the stuff you were breathing in the day before that you now swallowed in the middle
night. And so that's kind of caught in your throat right there. And the reason why we
swallow is to get into the acid to get rid of that. And so that's the idea here. And so
you can see some of those different things that are there. Now, again, other cellular
innate defenses, and this is now the second line of defense after the barrier. So pathogens
get in. We have phagocytic cells that recognize groups of pathogens with these TLRs, which
are called toaloid receptors. And these are nine different receptors. I think it's
still nine. There may be more now. But again, they recognize specific things from either
bacteria or viruses. And so again, some of the TLRs recognize lipopolysaccharide, which
is found in ground negative bacteria, flagelline, which is part of the flagella. We also have
the CPG DNA, which is recognized by TLR9. And then TLR3 recognize double-stranded RNA,
which is found in viruses. And so not only do we recognize bacteria, but we also recognize
pieces of viruses. And so we respond to those. When we eat those things, they respond to
it and trigger the immune system response. And so that's going to be another thing that
we see. Now, the two types of phagocytic cells in mammals are the neutrophils and the macrophages
and the neutrophils, again, are really active against bacteria. Think of these as little
pac-men, because all their job in life is to do is eat things, like, along, along, along,
and chop things up. The other interesting thing that's been out in the last 10, 15 years
is that these guys also spit their DNA out, kind of like Spider-Man. So what they do is
they release their DNA and it's kind of like a big fishing net. And when the DNA goes out,
they have histones on it, and the histones actually have antimicrobial properties. So
they trap the DNA in that net, and then they kill the bacteria in there, and then they kind
of bring back their DNA and kind of think of that. So think of the neutrophil, not only
it's just eating things, but also think of them as kind of like Spider-Man, where they
can shoot their DNA out, trap the bacteria, and then bring it in to eat. And so that's
kind of an interesting thing about them. Macrophages, again, where you probably will
see these, typically a macrophage is outside the blood, but when it's in the blood, we
call these monocytes. And so they have two rules. Not only do they eat, and so they're
very good at eating like pac-men against neutrophil, or like neutrophils, but they also then present.
And so I wouldn't say they're just active against fungi. I think this is a little simplistic,
but I think they're also very active against bacteria and viruses, because they're important
because they're kind of that in between the second and third-line infants. So these
are what are also known as antigen-presenting cells, because they present pathogens to the
T-cell saying, "I ate this. We've got to do something about this." Or they present this
to the B-cell and said, "I ate this. Let's do something about it." And so they're going
to be really important gateway between the second and third-line. And again, we'll talk
more about that next time in the next lecture. Now, the other cells that we have are these
dendritic cells. Again, they're called dendritic cells, because they kind of look like a neuron.
They have this big cell body, and then they have these dendrites that come off of them
that are used to kind of trap and activate. And so they stimulate the development of adaptive
immunity and contact with the environment -- that contact the environment like the skin. And
so, again, they're kind of these important mediators between the second and third-line
infants, because when they trap things, they then can present and show these to the T-cells
and the B-cells. And then the eosinophils discharge destructive enzymes. Again, these
are primarily for eukaryotic parasites. So if you ever want to know if you have a parasite,
have the doctor or the nurse do a blood count. If you're high in eosinophils -- so if you're
high in neutrophils, you have a bacterial infection. If you're high in eosinophils, your blood
count, normally these are very low, less than 1% in your blood. If it's higher than
2% or 3%, that probably means you have a eukaryotic parasite. It probably means you either have
a worm or some other type of eukary going on, and eosinophils are responding to the infection.
So that's one way you can tell if you have a parasite, either a worm or an intracellular
parasite or something like that. That's kind of floating around, and you look for your eosinophils.
And so, again, they have granules that release, and they go and kill and do a good job at killing
by releasing these enzymes, and that causes destruction.
Now, another type of cell that we have is called the natural killer cells, and they circulate
throughout the body to detect abnormal cells. And what they do is they go after cells that
are infected with a virus. And so, again, these are a need, because again, they're not specific,
but they'll look for cells that are in trouble. And so when the cells are in trouble, they
go in, they release enzymes and actually kill the cells. So they're looking for cells that
are infected with viruses or intracellular parasites that go in and kill the cell from
the inside out. And so, again, they release chemicals causing cell death, and they spread
virtually infected or virally infected or cancer cells. So they're going to play a real important
role with cancer as well. And again, a lot of these things you're going to see is the lymphatic
system, and the lymphatic system remembers the drainage. We're going to talk more about that
in the adaptive, because it's really important with the B&T cells. But think about this. These
cells are also there, looking at the fluid, getting returned back to the heart. If there's
anything there that's not supposed to be there, these guys respond. And so that's what you see there.
Now, some of the other proteins and peptides that we have include recognitions that attack pathogens
and impede the reproduction. One of the things are interferons, which provide innate defense with
interfering viruses, and they help activate macrophages. And they also kind of send out the
warning signal to other cells that the cell is being infected by a virus. A lot of times,
they'll send out interference and say, "Hey, I'm being infected. I'm being infected." Kind of the
silent alarm is triggering other cells to either start making defenses or signaling the macrophages
or NK cells to come eat me, because I'm not going to make it, and I need some help.
The other thing we have is the complement system. And this is a group of about 30 proteins, and you
can see they're labeled C1 through 9 in this situation. You have a couple different pathways.
And typically, it is either activated by antibodies, which are produced by the B cells that stimulate
it. Or again, a lot of times, you'll see it where you get activation through innate immunity. And
again, this is a series of proteins that cause cell lysis. So you can see cell lysis. So what
happens to the bacteria cells is it actually pokes holes. And we'll look at this again later on.
Where it pokes holes in the cell, so it puts these proteins in the membrane and it causes the
membrane to become leaky. It can lead to inflammation, again, leading to immune cell recognition and
immune cells coming into the site of infection. And then it can also do obstinization, which
targets antibodies to bind to the cell and flag and say, "Kill this." And so we'll see that as well,
especially with the adaptive. And so activation can lead to the lysis of invading cells. So it's
another innate system that you have that are just there to kill, kill, kill. So not only
phagocytes and that, but you also have these proteins that are there to respond and start killing
the cells. Now, another important thing that we have is called the inflammatory response. And so
such as pain and swelling is brought by molecules released upon injury or of the infection. And so
again, this allows for the cells to come out. And like I said, blood vessels are leaky. So when I
talked about this, capillaries are leaking. The reason why they're leaky is so that these white
blood cells can get to where they need to go. And so there's chemical mediators that say, "Hey,
we got an infection going on, especially if you have some break in the tissue or first line of
defense." These things get in. These cells leave the blood vessels so they either work their way
through the cell or through the cell gap junctions and they leak out into the system. And this is
where the fluid comes in. So when we think about the inflammatory response, typically we get heat,
redness, swelling, and pain. The heat is due to the vasodilation and that again brings out more
white blood cells to the side of the infection. The redness is again due to the vasodilation and
again the leakiness of the blood, so the redness. The heat also raising the temperature to kill the
microbes because again microbes can be temperature sensitive. You get the leakiness so you get swelling
which is the extracellular fluid. So the vessels leak out the fluid as well. And so you get swelling
where that tissue is damaged. And then finally you get pain because that swelling and the vasodilation
and all that hits the little nerves that are basically your pain receptors that respond to pain.
And so that's why you're typically with the four things of inflammation is redness, swelling, pain,
and heat. Those are the four classical signs. I'll do that again. Heat, redness, swelling,
and pain. So those are the things and that's due to again the things being released and becoming
into the site of the infection. So we see that going on. And again the enhanced blood flow
delivers the antimicrobial peptides. The results in accumulation of PUSH. PUSH which is a rich
in white blood cells, dead pathogens, and cell debris from damaged cells. And so again PUSH is a
good thing because that means your cells are eating these things up and spinning them out and killing
the stuff. So a lot of times you'll see especially with the skin scrape in that you may get some
mousine and stuff. That's good because that means your cellular response is working well.
It means you're getting the destruction of those cells, the pathogens, as well as the
surrounding tissue and that. And so that's a good thing that's going on there. And so like I said,
you may get swelling due to that increased amount of extracellular fluid and the pain that goes
along with it not only due to the injury, but also due to the extra fluid and cells in there
hitting the pain receptors. And so you see that as well. Now inflammation can be either
local or systemic throughout the body. And again, systemic is not normally a good thing. You want
it localized because it's good for fighting in a localized infection. If it's going systemic,
then you tend to have more problems. Now one of the responses that's triggered is fever. And like I
said, bacteria and that and pathogens tend to be temperature sensitive. So fever can be a good
thing. So when you have a low-grade fever, that means your body's responding to something that's
not supposed to be there. And that's normal. But when the fever gets too high, and again,
this is when it's too much of a good thing, that can cause problems because then we can have cell
problems, you know, our own issues with getting too high of a temperature. And then that's when you
want to seek medical treatment. But if you have a low-grade fever, sometimes just keep the advil
off to the side. If you can deal with it and that stuff and you know you're feeling it,
your body's natural way to fight these infections by raising the temperature to kill these bacteria.
Now there is something called septic shock. This is really when the body just gets all overwhelmed.
It's just like, it's kind of like you if you had a lot to do and you don't even know where to start.
And so it just piles up and you get so frustrated and it's overwhelmed that you're just like,
I can't do anything because I just don't know what to do. And that's what the body does. So when you
get this infection that starts triggering everything at once, the body just doesn't know how to respond
and says it goes, I don't know what to do and just shuts down. And so that can be bad. And so that's
what happens when you get this overwhelming infection due to an overwhelming inflammatory
response. So it's the body going too high and too much of again, a systemic response to an
infection. And so that can be bad as well. And then we hear a lot about chronic inflammation. And again,
that can be a threat to human health. And so again, inflammation can be good because you can get
progressive healing. And again, things like chemical ear intents, frostbite, cuts and lacerations
are stabbing, trauma, allergic reactions, burns and infection, these are all good things because
it can trigger healing. But if you have long term inflammation, it can be bad as well. So it can
lead to cardiovascular disease again, causing inflammation, especially in the vessels, which
can lead to fatty deposits, exposure of smooth muscle and other things that can lead to again,
coronary artery disease. Some people have sought that inflammation may lead to autism. So inflammation
in the brain can trigger those responses or maybe when during pregnancy and development.
Rheumatoid arthritis, we know this is due to allergic responses in that autoimmune disease
is progressive inflammation, where the body starts attacking itself, neurological disease. So things
like MS and other things where the immune system starts to attack the immune system or not the
immune system, but the nervous system. And so wears away at the myelin fibers. Alzheimer's
is one of those things that again, they think is due to inflammation of the nervous system and
then cancer as well. Because again, you get this outgrowing itself, a lack of response or
surveillance. And so that can lead to problems as well. So inflammation can be good, but too
much of a good thing can be bad. And so again, we want to keep this in check. And so we've heard
about these things now, people having chronic inflammation. And again, there's a lot of drugs
that lower that inflammation, drug like humera, which a lot of people are now taking for things
like Crohn's disease and other things, which are all autoimmune diseases. And it's when the immune
system is working too well or overacting and causing problems. And another one like that is
allergies. So when you have allergies and everything else, and you get too over sensitive to go into
anaphylactic shock, and that can be too, too much of a good thing. Again, more of a systemic response
than just a localized response. Okay, and then again, invasion of the innate immunity,
bad pathogens. And so adaptations have evolved in some pathogens that allow them to get into
phagocytes. And so you can see here is a list of either bacteria or some parasitic fungi,
or fungi or parasites, eukaryotic parasites that have worked their way in. And so what they do is
they say, yeah, go ahead and eat me up. But what they can do is then survive infection and destruction.
And so then they get transferred to other parts of the body, either by the monocytes,
or they live in the monocytes protected from the rest of the immunity. So they kind of trick
the system and hide by living inside the immune cells. So these guys have gotten smart in that
stuff. And again, we know a number of different bacteria and viruses and other pathogens, eukaryotic
pathogens that can do this as well. And again, you can see that where it again provides blocking
of those things. And so it doesn't either doesn't get in, doesn't get eaten, or prevents blocking,
or if they do get in, they can go and hide. And so that's the other thing as well, and then they
can escape later on. So okay, just an idea of avoiding phagocytosis as well. All right,
very short video, like I said, so the innate immunity is very easy. First line of defense,
second line of defense. First line is your barriers. So your physical and chemical barriers to keep
your protected. So that would be your skin, your mucous membranes, and the chemicals we produce on
the outside. Think of any opening to the outside world as a way for a pathogen to get in. So your
mouth, your nose, your ears, your eyes, your butt, again, rips in the skin, things like that,
those are going to be protected. And so the areas that I talked about, the mouth, the nose, the ears,
the eyes, the butt, your general system, those that'll have mucous membranes to trap and collect
those things. So the mucous membranes are important because not only does secrete mucus to trap
home microorganisms, but they also produce chemicals that destroy those as well. Okay. And so that's
important. Second thing is the second line of defense. Those are really the white blood cells
and the chemicals that they produce along with some of the other proteins that we have intracellularly.
Now, I wouldn't say intracellular, but extracellularly, that will respond to the pathogens. And again,
this all leads up to the third line of defense, which we're going to talk about next time.
And again, what we looked at was the first and second line of defenses. We found in both plants
and animals that have innate immunity. And again, as you work your way up to get more specialized
immune systems and more of a third line of defense, which we'll talk about next time,
again, we're born with these defenses. There's no specificity. So again, it doesn't matter if it's
a virus or bacteria. It's going to recognize or what type of virus or bacteria. It's just going to
go and attack, attack, attack. And again, we talked about the first and second lines and what they are.
And again, there are pathogens that can escape these defenses. And so for higher vertebrates,
like I said, we have an adaptive line, which we're going to talk about next time. And with that,
we've talked about innate immunity. Hopefully you got a better understanding about that. If you do
have questions about innate immunity and what it does or how it works, anything, please send me an
email or we'll talk about in class. Thanks for watching and I'll talk to you next time.